despite its religious veneer Islam can
easily be defined and understood by one
non-religious word tribalism this is key
the entire appeal of Muhammad's call to
the Arabs of his time lay in its perfect
compatibility with their tribal mores
three in particular loyalty to one's
tribe enmity for other tribes and raids
on the latter to enrich and empower the
former by the way I understand some of
you don't believe Muhammad ever existed
I'll definitely be addressing that down
the line but for now bear with me and
humor me if only because what Muslims
believe is much more important than what
actually happened but which can't be
proven one way or another more
Anon anyway for 7th Century Arabs and
later tribal and pastoral peoples such
as the Turks and tatars or Mongols who
also found natural appeal in and
converted to Islam the tribe was what
humanity is to Modern people to be part
of the tribe was to be treated humanely
to be outside the tribe was to be
treated inhumanely period this may be
hard for modern people living in the
west to understand but try Muhammad
reinforced this ancient dichotomy of
tribalism but by prioritizing religion
over relatives thus in his constitution
of Medina which he promulgated with
various non-muslim tribes in 622 he
asserted that quote a Believer shall not
slay a Believer for the sake of an
unbeliever nor shall he Aid an
unbeliever against a Believer moreover
all Muslims were to become quote friends
one to the other to the exclusion of
Outsiders unquote hence the umah which
is often translated as Muslim nation was
born emically connected to the word
mother um the umah came to signify the
Islamic super tribe a sort of universal
tribe that transcends racial National
and linguistic barriers encompassing any
and all who identify as Muslims and its
natural enemy remained everyone outside
of it again this is basic tribalism 1.0
though as mentioned with a religious
covering or vineer or consider the
Islamic doctrine
of which I talk about often which is
translated as loyalty and enmity or love
and hate Muhammad preached it and the
com and the Quran commands it taken
together for example Quran 5822 and 64
call on all Muslims to renounce and
disown their non-muslim relatives quote
even if they be their fathers their sons
their brothers or their nearest Kindred
end quote and to feel only enmity and
hatred for them until they believe in
Allah alone that is until they become
Muslim check out those verses sometime
assuming your English Quran translation
is an honest one anyway those two verses
Quran 5822 and 64 are referring to a
number of Muhammad's close companions
who According to Islamic history
renounced and eventually slaughtered
their own non-muslim relatives at as a
show of their loyalty to Allah Muhammad
and the Believers one slew his father
another his brother a third Abu Bakr the
first righteous khif tried to slay his
own son and Omar the second righteous
Khalif slaughtered several of his
relatives for more on Al see my 60-page
translation of Dr A alah's Treatise on
this Doctrine in my 2007 book the
al-Qaeda reader at any rate from here we
come to the Natural origin of jihad
tribalistic Blood Ties were exchanged
for religious ones thereby dividing the
world into two Mega tribes the Believers
in one tent and their natural enemies
the non-believers or infidels in another
and as we've seen the essence of
tribalism is Waring and praying on other
tribes in order to empower your own this
dichotomized worldview is actually
enshrined in Islamic law or Sharia as
mandate that Dar Al Islam the Abode of
Islam or the world of Islam must battle
dar
the Abode of non- Islam in perpetuity
until the former subjugates the latter
in for example the Encyclopedia of Islam
we read under the entry for Jihad that
quote the spread of Islam by arms is a
religious Duty upon Muslims in general
Jihad must continue to be done until the
whole world is under the rule of Islam
Islam must completely be made over
before the doctrine of jihad can be
eliminated in other words the doctrine
of jihad Warfare on the other is so
pivotal to Islam that without it Islam
ceases to be Islam's apotheosis or
deification of tribalism also explains
why tribal societies other than the
Arabs also gravitated to and found Islam
appealing consider the turkic people's
oldest epic the book of D corut although
newly converted to Islam the Turks of
this epic regularly engage in Pagan
practices banned by Islam they eat horse
meat drink wine and other fermented
drinks and their women are in comparison
to Muslim women relatively free and
independent it's only in the context of
raids on the other on the Infidel a
smooth and easy transition from raids on
the tribal Outsider that Islam finally
becomes evident in their lives here for
example is a typical pre-battle boast
from the Turks of the
Epic I shall raid the bloody infidels
land I shall cut off heads and spill
blood I shall make the Infidel vomit
blood I shall bring back slaves and
slave girls here is another typical
account of these new Turkish converts Pi
exploits quote they the early turky
converts destroyed the infidels Church
they killed its priests and made a
mosque in its place they had the call to
prayer proclaimed they had the
invocation or the shahada recited in the
name of Allah Almighty the best of the
hunting birds the purest of stuffs the
loveliest of girls they selected aside
from praying on the Infidel other which
already came natural to the pre-islamic
tur s any and all nonviolent aspects of
Islam fasting zakat pilgrimage are
totally absent from the lives of these
earliest turkic converts as portrayed in
the book of D corut even so the older
Muslim peoples the Arabs and Persians
praise the new converts simply because
they fight in the way of Allah waging
Jihad against the infidels to quote from
several
sources being committed to the Jihad has
always gone a long way to exonerate
otherwise unlam Behavior among Muslims
as if one group of Muslims is saying
well at least they're doing the hard
part war on infidels so let's give them
a break it was the same for those
Mongols who embraced Islam the tatars as
the Dominican frier roldo who died in
1320 and who spent about a decade in the
Muslim World once observed tatars had
adopted Islam because it was the easy
religion as Christianity was the hard
one in other words whereas Islam
complemented their pre-existing Tribal
Way of living including by giving them
license to pray on all Outsiders
Christianity only challenged it so it is
that Muhammad's most enduring
contribution to world history is that in
repackaging the tribal mores of 7th
Century Arabia through a theological
Paradigm he also deified tribalism into
a sort of hyper tribalism causing it to
outlive its historic setting and
dramatically spill into the modern era
hence the notorious resistance to
assimilation in the west the creation of
enclaves and clannish noo zones in
Europe and the constant flare outs of
hate crimes and terrorism whereas many
world civilizations have been able to
break away from or at least temper their
historic tribalism this has not been and
cannot be so easy for Islam for Muslims
to break away from tribalism is for them
to break away from Allah's laws laws
which as seen are logical and gratifying
at least from a primordial or if you
like primitive point of view